get away from you stole the show is
Johnny Cash and walk the line and do you
want us over as Arthur Fleck in the
Joker quite frankly Joaquin Phoenix we
can't wait to see what you get up to
next if your fans had it their way your
acting career would be even busier than
it is today if that's even possible they
can't wait to see your IMDB page to
light up with new productions like Joker
2 but in the meantime tell us what other
movies are you working on Joaquin
Phoenix is as unpredictable as Arthur
Fleck himself so there's no way of
knowing which movies he'll pop up in
will he reprise his role as Gotham's
most wanted criminal in Joker 2 or will
he take on Robert Pattinson 'he's Bruce
Wayne in the upcoming movie the Batman
keep watching to find out which movies
Joaquin is all set to star in and which
films his fans are hoping he'll be cast
in what could be more glorious
and to challenge the Emperor himself in
the great arena
Joaquin Phoenix has officially been cast
in come on come on in fact he's already
started filming the American drama in
New Orleans as of mid January 2020
director and writer Mike Mills has cast
actor Gaby Hoffmann alongside Joaquin
but little else is known about the
casting list according to River beats
Joaquin will play a documentary
filmmaker who's working on a project
that centers around gifted children the
actor was spotted on the set of c'mon
come on in New Orleans dancing with his
on-screen nephew in a Mardi Gras parade
so we can expect to see him show off his
Joker dance moves once again in the
upcoming flick and hopes are high for
some new meme worthy dance scenes come
on come on is slated to come out
sometime in 2020 be born as fans imagine
Joaquin Phoenix dusting off his brown
suede shoes they find themselves
wondering if the actor will be dusting
off his old guitar anytime soon who
could forget when Joaquin portrayed
Johnny Cash and walked the line back in
2005 his performance was so Chris it has
fans asking for a sequel after all these
years a fan who goes by the handle
three two one 9 a town asked for a
sequel on reddit saying the movie could
cover Johnny Cash's life after the
events of the original although walk the
line to isn't in the works whatsoever
some fans would love to see this movie
come to fruition but who knows maybe
Dewey Cox from walk hard will make a
cameo the Joker was such a big hit it
immediately had people talking about a
sequel The Joker origin movie grossed
over 1 billion dollars and quickly
became the best performing r-rated film
in Hollywood history so it's only
natural that fans want to see Joaquin
Phoenix reprise his role as the good
clown gone bad in Joker - while there is
no clear release date for the possible
sequel let alone a plot the project has
been added to Joaquin's IMDB page this
comes as a surprise to some as the star
has openly voiced his disdain for
franchises in the past but with the
movie's success refusing to reprise his
role as author Fleck would be a hard
thing to do while co-writer and
your todd phillips has denied sequel
rumors to the point of exhaustion it
looks like he might get on board after
all one of the many reasons the joker
was so entertaining had to do with its
bruce wayne subplot and now that Batman
has been confirmed fans are wondering if
these two movies intricate plots will
weave themselves together but according
to Todd Phillips
Joaquin's Joker will not star opposite
Robert Pattinson Batman
even then fans remain optimistic that
Joaquin will join the casting list as
the Batman is slated to come out
sometime in 2021 so there's plenty of
time to flip the script alongside
Roberts the Batman stars zoe kravitz as
Catwoman Colin Farrell as penguin and
Paul Dano as the Riddler whether or not
Joaquin joins the wicked casts there's
still a good chance that Batman and the
Joker will oppose each other in future
films my mother was delusional she was a
sick woman
Joaquin Phoenix is rumored to be
starring in the Casey Affleck upcoming
film far bright star the film's release
date has yet to be announced but
according to the cinema holic the actor
will portray a Calvary man who leads a
hunt in 1916 for Mexican revolutionary
Pancho Villa
the movie is based on Robert Armistead's
novel by the same name if Joaquin is
cast as a lead
he will portray Napoleon child's oddly
enough Johnny Cash's father ray cash was
involved in the Pancho via manhunt in
real life connecting the walk the line
starts a Johnny Cash in a whole new way
we don't know about you but we'd love to
see Joaquin Phoenix star alongside Keanu
Reeves in an action movie these amazing
actors would be perfect on-screen rivals
if you love the John wick franchise
maybe you'd be interested in seeing what
keen and Keano battle it out in John
wick chapter 4 the fourth installment is
rumored to be making its big-screen
debut sometime in 2021 and although it's
a long shot we're hoping to see what
Kim's name added to the casting list hey
people can dream can't they which
upcoming Joaquin Phoenix movie are you
most excited to watch and which movie
would you want to see him star in sound
off in the comments slave who became a
gladiator gladiator defied a number
movie roles Joaquin Phoenix needs to
star in thanks for watching don't forget
to Like and subscribe for more we'll see
you next time on two things
you